so we begin with that breaking news an
Ethiopian Airlines jet with 157 people
on board has crashed the boeing 737 max
8 took off from the capital addis ababa
bound for Nairobi in Kenya it came down
near the town of Bischoff - in eastern
ethiopia ethiopians Prime Minister has
tweeted his condolences for the 149
passengers and eight crew on board in a
message to families he wrote the office
of the prime minister on behalf of the
government and people of Ethiopia would
like to express his deepest condolences
to the families of those that have lost
their loved ones on Ethiopian Airlines
Boeing 737 on regular scheduled flight
to Nairobi Kenya this morning let's get
more from Al Jazeera's Catherine soy
who's on the line now from Nairobi we
understand Catherine that this aircraft
took off from Addis at 8:38 a.m. local
time what else do we know Catherine can
you hear me
al-jazeera's Catherine soy should be on
the line
she isn't I think we can we can talk to
Alex Metris who's an aviation analyst
who is joining us now via Skype that
from Malaga in Spain and it's good to
have you with us
ETA Vijay this aircraft it was a Boeing
737 max 8 am i right in thinking that
that's the same kind of aircraft that
crashed back in October the lion air the
crash in Indonesia good yes this is now
looking to be the second most major most
fatal incident for Boeing 737 max so the
737 max is the brand-new updated version
of the Boeing 737 the max itself is in
service all around the world and IDEs
include Norwegian Air Italy Ethiopian
who are a member of star
Alliance and airlines such as Ethiopian
Airlines are using this aircraft as its
the latest the most fuel-efficient shoe
range Boeing aircraft on the market this
aircraft that has been involved in the
accident today is less than four months
old it was delivered to Ethiopian in
mid-november it flew from the US it made
a fuel stop in Ireland and was delivered
to addis ababa which is the airport that
is Ethiopian Airlines hub and they uses
up to channel passengers through it and
then to distribute them elsewhere on
that route network the 737 max Alex was
was Boeing's answer to air buses what
a320 or the new version more
fuel-efficient of the version of the
a320 after that the lion air crash a
lion air crash in Indonesia the Air Line
Pilots Association of of the u.s. told
US safety regulators that the union was
current concerned about a potential
significant aviation system safety
deficiency in the Boeing 737 max
aircraft what's wrong with it I think we
should be careful there because
ultimately new aircraft do have that
hiccups now that's not to say that they
are unsafe or that they are more prone
to being involved in an accident but
there are certain advisories for lots of
new aircraft and that's perfectly normal
as they enter the marketplace to pick up
on what you said the Boeing 737 max was
kind of initiated in response to Airbus
is a320neo so that's the new engine
option both of these aircraft including
the 737 max these are typical
traditional Boeing 737 designs with
modifications to make the aircraft more
fuel efficient so it's a new aircraft
based upon one of Boeing's bestsellers
the 737 which is in service all around
the world and if you have ever flown
short ball then I guarantee you probably
flown on a 737 it's a popular choice of
the airline's it's a very safe
but of course there are now questions
and this will send jitters across the
industry as this is a brand new aircraft
that has now been its most second fatal
accident in the space of less than five
months the first one of course was the
lion air seventh that was just in
October late October
I suppose one of the things that makes
this aircraft so attractive thought for
airlines is that if they've already got
a 737 s in their fleet this brand new
version of it even though it has new
systems in it doesn't require the pilots
to undergo expensive training courses in
order to be able to fly it in theory
they could just relatively simply go
from from one version the older version
of the 737 so this new version
absolutely and this is what Boeing
specialize with with the 737 max
commonality is key and so there are real
there are no real significant changes
when flight crew are converting from the
existing 727 to flying the 737 max there
is a very short involved and for this
reason it's very economical for the
airlines but again this is very normal
Airbus doing exactly the same they want
to focus on commonality maybe it helps
that bottom line financially but to
bring things back to Ethiopian Airlines
they have taken an array of new aircraft
and important further bearing on it for
this airline specifically is that they
need aircraft that they know can be
proven to work very reliably from Addis
Ababa airport which is ultimately on the
scale of things very hot and very high
intemperate in altitude so when I met
with it of Ethiopian Airlines in China
in September he was explaining to me
that not all aircraft available on their
marketplace was an option to eat because
all of them could demonstrate their
reliability from an airport such as
addis ababa which ultimately attitude is
significantly higher than it were from
landing from
across the world so for this reason this
airport is quite specific in its needs
and requirements from very briefly
Alex Lyon air had the the Indonesian
airline that had this brand-new Boeing
737 max that the crashed back in October
had let's say about a questionable
reputation as far as maintenance and
safety was concerned that doesn't apply
to Ethiopia does it because I mean that
they have as you say this this brand-new
fleet and they look after those aircraft
very well extremely safe there should be
no doubt in the aircraft at this point
until we find out further further
information believe the open airlines in
South Africa one of the best airlines on
the continent
Alex many thanks indeed Lousma Charis
there are a VA ssin analyst let's hear
now from al jazeera's catherine soy who
is on the line from nairobi catherine we
were talking just a few minutes ago
about that that statement made by
Ethiopia's prime minister tell us more
yes
we started by seeing this tweet the
Prime Minister's Office the Ethiopia
prime minister's office offering
condolences to relatives of passengers
who are on board that flight and then
the airline itself has issued a
statement saying that and rescue
operations going on they haven't given a
number of any special and they have
given details of what happened and this
light because as a 8:38 a.m. local time
from Addis Ababa the capital of Ethiopia
and they lost contact at around 8:30 say
that six minutes after but when the
aircraft dropped from the radar the
southeastern town of shopton 149
passengers is mentioned and eight crew
on board the airline saying that a
passenger information center is being
set up and stressed - world where
relatives who are trying to find out
what has happened
to their laptops are as opposed to
getting happy that name just to find out
what's going on and to be updated about
what's going on in distress fashion
rescue operation all right Catherine
many thanks did Catherine saw it
reporting live there from Nairobi just
to were to recap then Ethiopian Airlines
flight number et 3:02 with 157 people on
board that's eight crew and 149
passengers has crashed shortly after
taking off from addis ababa bound for
Nairobi in Kenya the aircraft
registration of ETA VG was a Boeing 737
max eight delivered in November last
year it is the same aircraft the same
type of aircraft that crashed in October
the lion air 737 max eight crash of
Indonesia in October last year more
details on that breaking news as and
when we get it here on al-jazeera